non-minimalists
how is your message similar to or
different from marie condo and looking
for the joy and beauty in the things you
own
so let's talk about this i don't think
our i don't think we're appreciably
different from marie kondo although i
think the big difference here is
how people interpret the messages yes
and so people often hear about marie
kondo and they think oh it's just about
decluttering my closet i don't think she
would say that but i think a lot of
people see and now i get you know she's
selling a bunch of things at the
container store or whatever and while i
personally dislike that i think the
container store is part of the problem
it allows us to hide all the clutter in
very neat looking bins and it doesn't
allow us to address the problem but if
we set that aside
marie condo does understand getting to
the why behind simplifying right but
people see it and they're like oh i see
how to fold my shirts better and that's
going to fix my life yeah well if you
think folding your shirts better is
going to fix everything for you then
you've set yourself up with an
unfortunate expectation
and and you're going to fold all the
shirts repeatedly it's going to be
perfect but it's not going to change
anything in your life
it's going to make things a little bit
tidier a little bit more organized but
organizing is actually the problem
organizing our stuff is just taking a
bunch of things that are making us
miserable they're covering up our
happiness our joy our genius
and they are getting us to a place where
okay i can hide this for a while but it
still covers up all of the things that
make life beautiful of course the
easiest way to organize your home or
your stuff is to get rid of most of it
get rid of those things that aren't
serving a purpose don't put them in a
container store
container
that just
that's punting the problem yeah next
year just covering it up yeah hmm erwin
so you know marie condo i don't oh you
don't oh interesting the life yeah
changing magic of tidy i don't know
that's not the name of the book but it's
something like that that's exactly it oh
the life-changing magic of tidying up
yeah okay um okay well then never mind i
was going to see what he saw the
differences were but if he doesn't know
who she is no i just think it's
interesting that someone asks you what's
the difference as if
or
almost like it feels like why do you
exist if she exists ah yes oh yeah and
i'm going why does coldplay exist when
you two exist why you know why did the
rolling stones exist when the beatles
existed if something is of value you
want more expressions if it not last
right yeah you know so my my question
was
why not like why does there have to be
i mean there's going to be differences
right sure because
to me the difference with you is that
it's your story
it's your journey
you're you're really not um philosophers
of minimalism
you you are um practitioners of
minimalism sure and you're taking people
into the story of your life and then how
it's changed you and then you're helping
other people have their own story right
and so i'm like perfect for example i
haven't been touched by her but i have
been touched by you
and and i'm sure there are people that
have been touched by her that maybe have
not yet even heard about you guys as the
minimalist and um when something matters
there should be multiple frequencies and
multiple narratives getting the message
out yeah i love that so the end result
is you know maybe it's the same but yeah
it's a different narrative it's a
different path to
to that that result and the question is
what resonates with you right ryan and i
often talk about the why how might your
life be better with less sounds like a
how-to question but it's a it's a why
question disguised as a how-to question
so
when we ask that question
it's really about understanding
why or the benefits of simplifying
because if you're just folding the
shirts you're just cleaning out the
walk-in closet but you don't know why
you're doing that you're just going to
the container store and organizing yes
you will feel a weight lifted but you
won't experience lasting contentment by
simply tidying up you have to understand
why you're doing it what are those
benefits for you maybe they're financial
maybe they're spiritual maybe they're
allow you to improve your career or your
creativity maybe they just give you a a
house that is calmer for you and that
brings out the best version of you maybe
it's more peace and tranquility maybe
it's happiness what are the benefits of
simplifying for you and then of course
the how to side of things that tends to
take care of itself we talked earlier
about that recipe for michael jordan
like could you imagine if like i
actually did look
at the recipe that michael jordan used
and my expectation was i'm going to
become how
disappointed i would probably be
depressed yes if i followed all that
because now i'm not special i'm not
uh you know whatever it is like i'm
going to feel inadequate it's the same
thing with
the the the the life-changing magic of
tidying up if you follow marie condo's
exact recipe
yeah you may have a less
uh cluttered home you might be a little
bit more organized but you're not going
to be marine condo if you follow josh
and i's rest but you're not going to be
josh and i uh but what's really cool
about marie kondo and us there are
different recipes there are different
paths even between josh and i are
different recipes and you get to pick
and choose your own ingredients and make
your make your own delicious minimalism
recipe
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free